here was Megan Rino's argument as to why
God does not exist a long one although
I'm I'm going to get the Aaron Rogers
treatment whatever that is um so I'm
gonna be calling him or whoever did his
surgery because we need to speed this up
but yeah I thought about a little bit I
mean you know I'm not a religious person
or anything and if there was a god like
this is proof that there isn't this is
up um the argument is an argument that a
lot of Reddit tier atheists make which
is because of bad thing happened to me
that's proof that God does not exist but
you know this is an old problem that
people have been grappling with for uh
ever and it's theodicy it's the problem
of pain and suffering given a God who is
om omnipotent and Omni benevolent and
omnipresent suffering is not a proof
against God's existence because
suffering has no moral quality in and of
itself it is the reaction to suffering
that has a moral quality